in the heart of a quintessentially
English Village in the home counties a
building which used to describe itself
as the perfect location for a wedding
but not anymore
most of the signage has been taken down
but it's no secret this is a hotel which
is now being used to house dozens of
Asylum Seekers much to the consternation
of some locals they don't know where
they're from they don't know the
backgrounds they see them in groups of
men and just probably feel uneasy do you
think it's changed the atmosphere in the
community I think yeah people uh because
I speak to a lot of locals in the
village they usually let their kids roam
around The Village at night you know
when to play with the bikes now some of
them are like thinking twice Mo Tariq is
an estate agent he says the arrival of
Asylum Seekers has caused rent prices to
drop I feel like maybe we should have
some system in place something for them
to do here because what often happens in
My View From Where I'm sitting is that
they will just stand around and they
look like almost they have nothing to do
in fact the Asylum Seekers tell us
they're bored and unhappy they're not
allowed to work whilst waiting for their
claims to be processed and that can take
a long time this man from Eritrea has
been in this system for eight years for
me is absolutely terrible it's not good
it's not good you just leave just eat go
back to the room it's your day you eat
your battery that's all day
there's a backlog of nearly 40 000
Asylum Seekers who've made it to the UK
their accommodation is costing taxpayers
five and a half million pounds a day
Abdullah is from Tanzania I'm not happy
in the hotel and I'm not happy in this
old situation about home office because
I'm office they they send me message to
ask to grant me about accommodation and
support but they didn't they didn't give
me enough support some people may say
that if you're unhappy with the food
you're unhappy with the accommodation
why don't you return to Tanzania because
Tanzania is a safe country so when I go
back to home country
the the uh I'm gonna die they're gonna
kill me he's
uh
society and government as well because I
have a problem against the society and
government what's the problem I'm gay
man it's not lost on the Asylum Seekers
that some people find their presence
intimidating but whilst they're stuck in
the immigration system there's little
opportunity to integrate Lisa Holland
Sky News